the end of a long journey for the family
of Aiden mcanaski they'd waited three
decades and were overwhelmed by the
sense of justice At Last for their
brother
we had 34 years
I never thought it would have got it
I'm thinking of
my father Elish Aiden
and my mother
that prayed and prayed for this day and
are not here to see it 23 year old Eden
mcanaski was shot dead in 1988 after
walking through this military checkpoint
close to okner Chloe and County Tyrone
former Grenadier Guardsman David Holden
seen here in the cup claimed he'd fired
the shots from his machine gun
accidentally but he knew the victim was
a person of interest to security forces
and the judge did not believe him
this judgment comes as the British
government presses ahead with
legislation to end the prosecution of
soldiers for historical offenses in
Northern Ireland it offers a de facto
amnesty to anyone who's prepared to
engage with a new truth recovery body
but victims and campaigners want the
bill scrapped they say this verdict is
evidence that Justice is still possible
the argument is always that the passage
of time will leave it almost impossible
to get to the truth this
ruling today actually blows out into the
water and says it is possible for all
their families and we would encourage
them we're going to ask your family and
everyone here would encourage all their
families do not give up hope
outside Court those protesting against
the prosecution of veterans expressed
support for the bill and said David
Holden would appeal veterans I can say
will be deeply disappointed by this
verdict
um I'm saddened by it but it's not over
for David yet
I understand that the family gonna feel
completely different to US veterans and
they will
have their their time to to say what
they say but for us the Witch Hunt
continues
the machinespi's say Aiden and his
parents can finally rest in peace but
the debate over the legacy of the
troubles is far from over David Blevins
Sky News in Belfast